it's not getting to a place and saying
we're here
and now we're here and we're going to be
a static form
for the rest of our lives because we're
here doesn't work that way
i think what's needed are techniques
okay so there's a lot of conversations
like conversation we're having now and
conversations can be really meaningful
and
you know your show has literally been
it's been trans
and transformative you were going to say
transcendental transit
like no i was like no transfer quite
been transcendental no
i think it i think it definitely has
been for many many many people so i'm
not saying
that conversation isn't helpful it is
but when you get down to it
you can't really know something that you
read in a book or that you hear somebody
else say
you have to experience it for yourself
which is why life experience is so
valuable
all kinds of life experiences but i
think
it's the techniques of meditation of
yoga nidra of sitting in tea ceremony of
being present it's the will it's the
calling to divine it's the choosing to
experience life
as a divine journey that cultivates
these energetic
experiences that become a knowing inside
of you
and then when you have the knowing uh
you know you're really there's a
saying that truth doesn't defend it
simply
is so here you are in the state of being
you know a being who's rooted in being
isn't going to go fight for peace or
argue about which political party it's
like
it's like there's a power in staying
quiet staying quiet i'm not saying you
don't do anything and you go to a cave
and you don't live
but staying quiet until you're really
aligned with what is true for you
and if you're really aligned with that
then you can really be effective
in your actions in your politics
in your love for planet earth in
whatever you're doing
but if you've never taken the time to
know yourself
you're you're not there you're just
spouting off what someone else says
you're retweeting something
thinking that you did something good um
and
you know and this is you know water
tiger this is
my spiritual mentorship program is a
body of techniques
so it's a way to no way i'm not claiming
to know what anybody's path is
i'm been down the road a few years and
i've
spent a lot of time in study in these
areas
in this list this lifetime and also in
other lifetimes
so i offer some body of techniques that
uh
may help people it is helping people
they are helping people
to access um a connection with
themselves
which is a direct connection with
source so in the process of
of being engaged with this community on
water tiger and i know
you do these sort of private sessions
with lots of people
what are the things that are coming up
like what are the common themes what are
people struggling with and experiencing
right now
in this you know one year demarcation of
the
pandemic well it's profound i mean i
think i'll share
uh you know um i mean obviously you
can't i can't sure who it is but i'll
share generally about the last two
sessions that i
facilitated actually um one is a water
tiger member and one is
on their way to becoming a water tiger
member
um there's there's real life happening
to all of us right now
and um one of the experiences is an
individual
who's uh whose friend
um hung himself and he's the one who
went in and found him so that was one
experience that i facilitated a
um an empowerment
a love a blessing um a sort of
reformatting perspective so that we can
extract the treasure from
such horror so that's one
and i'll and i'll get into some of what
i've gleaned from these is
very profound right now and also
connected to
uh the essence of shrimu and and what
that is to me
um is uh this
opportunity to find beauty
in all life and
you know you're you might be thinking
well how in the hell
could you find beauty in such a horrific
event for all individuals involved
um you know they're that's somebody's
child that's somebody's brother
it's somebody's lover it's somebody's
friend you know
it's so final you can't change that
it's a it's a it's something that
to me in my experience is the
opportunity to render us on our knees
and for the very quality of that
experience
it is a divine experience beyond measure
because it's maybe one of the only
experiences
that we can't reason our way out of
we can't quantify it or or say something
positive
or change it it's so final
in in this realm
another experience from a water tiger
member
is an artist that has worked with me
and we are exploring beauty as the first
tenet of a spiritual life
so you may look at me from the outside
and say
well if she was really spiritual why
does she wear makeup
and why does she fix her hair why is she
wearing a dress
or why did she create shrimpu that's
this big you know beautiful
aesthetically you know sort of developed
product and and the reason is because
beauty is
the first tenet of a spiritual life that
is what makes us
uh connected to life around us and so
within my ritual within my practices of
coaching people and helping people i am
helping
us to remember that we have the power to
find beauty
in all life experiences um
this other artist that i was working
with that i'm working with
she's been asking for a communication
about her role as being a steward of
sacred art
and we're talking about the ability to
program art with intention
to be in ritual and communion before we
start to
create the art and how could we use art
as a vehicle
of beauty being the first tenet of
spirituality
that can transform the planet that can
you know lift our experience of life
here by
healing us by feeding us
by nourishing us and
she had a very visceral sort of
transcendental experience using the
water tiger techniques
and she had a complete she was given a
body of work
exactly the way it looks and exactly
you know the format and the date that
she needs to do it by and all these kind
of things
and also very connected to some deep
suffering in her journey
that she had to face that was very
probably the thing
that was the hardest thing for her so in
my work
the greatest treasure is in the trauma
and so when i work with somebody i'm
looking for the thing they never told
anybody
i may be the first person that they
shared it with or the thing that is
absolutely irreconcilable and if i
am lucky enough and blessed enough to
serve
my purpose by the end of that session
they have a different perspective on on
the events
right and that that tracks back to this
idea of
everybody has something that they're
hiding from or that they're hiding from
the world or that they're hiding from
themselves
and to the extent that you can muster
the courage to actually look at that to
deconstruct that and find the gem or the
meaning
or the beauty or the opportunity in that
that's where the crux of transformation
begins and this has always been your
thing with me
and when we weathered all of our
challenges and difficulties it's like
how do we flip this and look at it
from a perspective of opportunity rather
than
victimhood like why is this happening to
me isn't this terrible
instead like this is your divine moment
like this is the opportunity that you've
been waiting for and just that
mental shift as difficult as that might
be
or as kind of counter-intuitive or or
challenging to like inhabit that in your
body
um i've i've found that to be incredibly
powerful
i've seen you do that in the context of
our family and i've seen you do that
with so many other people
definitely and and and
let it be beautiful is sort of one of my
mantras my mantras
it's like let it be beautiful whatever
it it may be scary
it's not autopilot it's not acting like
everything is the same it's not getting
to a place and saying
we're here and now we're here and we're
going to be a static
form for the rest of our lives because
we're here
doesn't work that way it's always
changing and no matter how difficult
whatever the evolution is whatever needs
to be looked at
it has to be beautiful it has to be
beautiful because
life is divine it's sacred this is a
privilege it's a divine privilege to be
in a body at this time
and we are co-creating our experience
with our life
[Music]
you